good afternoon everyone nice to see you
too isn't everything recorded all the
time pretty much not that we can get at
it but so this is a somewhat misleading
title or a appropriate title for work
that is in very early and preliminary
form and so all this will be be
front-loaded would talk mostly about
context and I hope that the context is
useful for for you and thinking about
the sorts of security controls and
privacy controls and applications in
which you're going to put them because
our our goal is to using an empirical
case to look at different uses of data
and match them to different technical
controls this is collaborative work the
wreck
Co conspirators include my low long-time
co-conspirator at the Census Bureau and
two of my students at various places
most of what I will talk about because
it is all context is actually based on
previously published work a lot of that
has been with these project
collaborators and other members of the
Harvard University privacy tools group
and this and some of the the background
work is supported in part by the sloan
foundation the disclaimer if you if you
like anything as I said it's all shared
with my collaborators and
co-conspirators if anything I say is
stupid or wrong or you don't like it
it's entirely my fault
because they nobody approved these
slides
nor did MIT nor Sloan or any other
organization and so unless it was
written down and published with their
names on it it's it's my fault and for
the things that we're written down and
published with mutual names on it that's
and you can pretty much assume and if
you see a real figure or table here or
anything that looks like it was drawn
from one of these things so what's the
broader context of use and risk for
government information some previous
work we tend to think about the direct
decisions the official decision in
communication and the trade-off between
the social value of setting the setting
the deep or Shimon right versus
revealing information about individuals
the harms of that information versus
that main social decision but there are
two other types of functions of
government information that are also
very important that may suggest other
modes of access and these include
research that broader the broader social
benefit from research and business uses
and public transparency and
accountability understanding how the
information was was produced being able
to to replicate to verify
and the harm of information the the
threats from information depends on its
also is also contextual and we've been
thinking talking a lot about limiting
access to information and different ways
in which that can be limited and the the
harm from information also depends on
the sensitivity of the information which
we characterize as a combined threat and
vulnerability analysis and you you can
see this in this is an illustration of
from the berkeley law and technology
journal paper cited earlier of this
trade-off between the relationship
between identifiability which we we
characterize as rough some rough measure
of how much you can learn about an
individual because they participated in
this the state of collection and what
would what harm might you expect
sensitivity what could you expect from
having that data released in the wild
and that information be some adversary
learning from that about an individual
and taking some use of it so if the the
risk is very small we might not have
much protection at all say and here
we're not not talking about the the in
sensitivity sensitivity is not
necessarily one mapped one-to-one with a
particular type of attribute this
requires a more you know detailed
analysis but if if you an information
release might have has a low probability
of downstream harm then you might just
release it under consent or or if you
can manage the the risk of someone
learning from that through some formal
protection mechanism you could also
release with lighter protections even if
the the risk is higher
and so when we're thinking about how to
make data available we have to consider
not just we have to consider what the
objective of the uses what the what the
mode not just the the mode of analysis
but what the objective of the use is how
much can be learned from data and how
that's controlled and what the the
threats are from the data release and we
these can be the threat surface can be
changed by changes in data collection of
the environment and this is from 2018
paper cited consider you know a one-time
data collection I hear a weather app
that collects your collects your
information
or at registration okay
collects your default location at
registration
the risk of identifying you from just
that that data point are fairly small
but we know as we repeatedly measure the
same unit over time that we can that
behavioral fingerprints emerge so if you
can see a person or observe what you
know is is an individual even if you
don't know who that individual is and
you can make repeated measurements of
their behavior especially in space and
time you are more likely to to be able
to compute some sort of behavioral
fingerprint on them that allows you to
connect that pattern of behavior to
another to to a record another database
and so there identifiability potential
fire identify ability goes up and the
risk goes up even if you're not
measuring additional information if you
were to to increase this data collection
so that instead of say checking having
the weather app check once a day for
your your location it monitored her at
every every second continuously every
tenth of a second that may reveal
different that that level of information
actually may reveal different patterns
of information it may allow you to make
inferences about different patterns of
behavior for example how often does
somebody go to the gym where are they at
particular time how what's their walking
speed which might be relevant to health
and so that expands the the set of
inferences that you could make and
pushes risks out to them to the right as
well as going up if ask you as you
increase the and so these are some
examples of risk factors
that are related to big data and a
temporal sense we've done other other
risk factors but we were looking for
Boyd and what happens with time factors
when you when when the the data you
collect is older or rather when there's
a increased time between the time of
data collection and release of a
computation on that data the individuals
characteristics might have changed
during that time so there may be some
decrease in the ability to to match that
to available available external data
maybe reduces the identifiability
as time goes on the the number of
purposes for that unanticipated purposes
for that data might increase we learn
different things that different sorts of
inferences at least this has been the
history in recent time of that we could
make from particular data collections
and so I think that the the number of
threats we didn't for for example when
ran a a an archive for qualitative
social science and we have videos of
people talking to each other and for
four years people would use only the
transcripts because that was all they
write you they wouldn't go back to the
videos because that was essentially the
information that they understood to be
in the data and that was readily
accessible even though we had the videos
and but over time we realized that you
could you know through voice tremors you
could detect disease indicators you
could detect cognition you might be able
to pick up pulse rate from video you so
that there are many more signals many
more inferences that we can extract and
and use and we expected and after after
some amount of time people died and so
they're not vulnerable to the direct
information harm of somebody yeah what
so these different risks of age of the
data how what period which is this sort
of span of human behaviors that you're
able to make inferences about if you
collect data over yeah frequently and
over a long enough time you may be able
to make inferences about domains that
emerge at different time scales business
behavior might be seasonable seasonal at
the yearly level some human behavior
emerges at the daily level some emerges
over a much shorter time scale and the
frequency the data collection
affects both your identifiability and
and some of the inferences you can make
so we're thinking so to match uses and
harms we have to think both about the
these characteristics of harms only the
identifiability but what are the risk
factors for threats and vulnerabilities
that create sensitivity and we've talked
a lot about inferential controls but
there's a whole set of controls in which
this these inferential controls are
embedded procedural economic educational
legal technical this is a what red arrow
yeah okay let's just faint say it's an
invisible laser laser pointer this
section is an example from a larger a
larger catalog of of things we put
together and each of these can be
applied at different sequence in the
data curation process some of these are
applicable at multiple stages you could
choose to apply them at collection at
release after the fact
for technical controls we have both from
the technical and and somewhat from the
legal point of view started to divide
controls into what they're you know two
broad areas of purpose controls on
computation and controls on computation
include model servers they restrict the
the types of queries you could make on
the data but not directly anything else
you can only make this query or answer
this specific computation and emerging
controls are things like functional
computation encryption home morphic
encryption public lecture which don't
don't restrict the the computations but
add some property those computations
that they're record of them we've talked
a lot about differential privacy which
is agnostic to the computation but but
limits how you can learn for those
conversate computations about the
observed inference observed unit its
control and inference a lot of a lot of
legal controls are about neither of
these five controls on purpose which is
the domain of human activity to which
the inferences are applied you can use
this for research but not for credit
reporting purposes it doesn't matter if
you yeah if you made a particular
computation or you learned about an
individual it may be barred and they you
know the gdpr
has limits purposes on almost all all
dated some extent
so one of the
one of that the preliminary conclusions
we do is mapping some of these risks
highlight these emerging risks to
different approaches and there are a
range of approaches in which probably
some level of human control secure data
Enclave formal formal oversight is going
to be required because the risk from
high dimensional high frequency data is
not manageable with adequate utility
guarantees I think there are two that
they're going to be two two reasons
where you that things that might might
guide your choice of control one is what
you know what's the risk or what's that
what's what are the characteristics of
the data they create create risk so at a
particular level and particular types of
risk differentially private analysis for
high frequency high dimensional data
don't know how to do that very well and
so there's no there's no reason to
believe that we can we can limit it to
some reasonable risk and still allow any
utility on the data at this point and so
we might end up saying we need other
mechanisms there may also be things like
where where the objective is individual
analytics
where the the mode of analysis or even
the objective of the analysis is
incompatible with the mechanism
of and so then you you might also choose
a different different variants and so
things like if you if you want to allow
data to be if you want to permit
surveillance and trace back to a
particular person multi but but limit
the types of surveillance that are
better possible or when it's used
something that differential privacy is
not going to allow you to do that it's
designed to not do right but you could
you could envision doing that with
personal data stores and and computable
policies with doing that but having a
audit log of the surveillance act you
know the computations that were run for
surveillance doing that and through some
restricting the types of queries that we
could be run through multi-party
computation but allowing those queries
sometimes to to have inferences that
that yield information about a
particular individual
so this was front-loaded
so this is to do the to start on the the
matching in particular case we started
to look at how our can we classify how
government data is disseminated now and
there are quite a different number of
modes of dissemination from single
published estimates to interactive
lookups to dynamic tables and maps to
public use to direct access to to the
underlying data and restricted data
centers and are there traces of use of
these both either either direct from
access logs to query servers or
applications to use restricted data
sources are their traces that use from
the results and published analyses
researchers describe what they you how
what methods they ran on the data what
they linked it with etc and are there
indirect indicators of use through
social media mentions etc because
business uses tend not to publish a
whole lot and these are the sorts of
things we are looking to inform what
data wrangling occurs what where
external data sources are used where
there are individual cleaning operations
that involve inspecting individual data
points for example for or linking
operations maybe expect for typos or
something like that
statistical the statistical computing
approach whether it's based on query
some queries linear models likelihood
estimation Bayesian estimation other
related Diagnostics methods data
characteristics what unit of analysis
are they aiming aiming at whether time
dimensions and other other structure of
data that they may be merging in as
they're a network structure spatial
video and presentation are the the
analytics and results all presented at
the at the level of population
coefficients model estimates and
predictions are are their their
individual data points presented at part
of the analysis either as Diagnostics or
our visualizations or the and we have
not we have completed the data
collection process for the most part we
have not completed the data wrangling
process to any that we've done topic
modeling and some different sorts of
text mining approaches on some of these
as well as hand coding so I do not have
any any overall prevalence analysis
except to say we even find evidence of
all of these types of uses or linking
that they're doing individual attempting
to do as low level as available to use
all of these different methods to
present individual data directly to use
the diagnostics and
so I will and with some some conclusions
or provocations about five minutes early
before the discussion time I know giving
us five maybe three to five more minutes
for discussion and you can read them as
conclusions from provocations you wish
one summary is that one size does not
fit all given the the variety of uses
and goals
you should anticipate that tier two
access will be necessary to address
those major uses
yes it's important when that government
data supports multiple objectives
epilate those uses and these may have
different use characteristics and that
the informational controls vary and
compatibility a model server that gives
you a regression estimate may be may be
very useful if you know you want to run
that regression and you are not not very
careful about regression Diagnostics but
it may be as a strong person example too
weak to protect formally because you can
if you can run an infinite number of
regressions you can extract the data and
r2 and and too strong to prevent
thoughtful use of the data because
although what you are publishing is the
regression coefficient in order to
perform the analysis you need to do
diagnosis you need to do data analysis
of data for data cleaning the link in
data etc and some some provocations
discovery research may require access
beyond limits at formal protections
there's a lot of research that we are
not good at at describing formally their
regeneration process Trey's saying
synthesizing novel sources that data
often involves going back and forth to
see how does this data correspond data
once this is understood and it becomes a
matter of a policy analysis or applied
research or estimation you may be able
to then find a formal formal method that
will give you these results on a new
data set with some action but this this
process of discovering and yes there's a
threat to the Lydda T here is a
different one and research often seems
to involve both a a discovery phase that
theory and an application phase
representative uses isn't taking one
example is unlikely to two
I'm unlikely to be a good test
considering multiple different uses for
multiple different objectives and levels
and the tensions between providing those
is a lot harder than you know pretty
much any specific most of the specific
uses we could we could probably think of
a way to deal with and and worst-case
analysis this is definitely provocation
aren't so we see some methods like
differential privacy takes a worst-case
analysis to to privacy risk and that you
consider what what's the what's the most
you could learn from a particular
information release so what's the upper
bound of the the informational harm you
could get to that individual title
thirteen also takes a worst-case
analysis we should not allow any any
informational risk on the other hand the
trade-offs were often in the same
analysis we're applying average case
analysis to use in utility consider how
like increasing epsilon might affect our
our main square error but not that's not
the worst case impact on the on the
research or analysis your question so
it's not comparing worst cases in
average cases and at the same width tie
it with and we're often optimistic about
operational information of this
going from a a system where there's a
you have known people and strong legal
sanctions to one where you have a formal
way but which provides you no formal
guarantees of information loss at all to
one that is formally formally guarantee
but implemented in an automated model
server brothers they implement it wrong
there could be you create information
security vulnerabilities it's not that
there sits there's a straightforward
trade-off but we tend to we most
analysis don't look at all all sources
of all sources of risk and in comparing
these approaches so it would
efforts going forwards consider the
context of use and the particular
vulnerabilities and threats that your
you're trying to manage these on the
overall you surface questions arguments
observations
[Applause]
[Music]
so
when you talk about risk inferential
risk actually I wanted to mention I mean
this raised two questions you know - oh
you specified is it always understood
that the risk is of the identification
or if they're real is there some other
kind of risk that you considered to be
no that basically consider the they'll
we talk in terms of harm and harm is
something someone's life going worse
than it would otherwise in some
significant way you're not you know
what's what's the likelihood that be
caught for because of some information
release something bad happens to that
person and they're they're their life
because that information was available
is shorter or less happy and less income
they have less health that's the harm
you're trying to prevent there are a
number of channels for that harm vulner
ways that you could imagine that harm
occurring and that release of
information provides makes them more
vulnerable so we we take we this is
often just compacted into what a
sensitivity of the data so we think of
you know we call oh that's tough all of
that analysis sensitivity and then we
call the the informational risk what you
can what what you what you likely learn
the the privacy and overall balance
so since that the sentence something
that happens external to your system I
mean I'm not this isn't anything it's
just really to try and figure out and
you'll see it kind of relax and an
interesting way to talk about yeah I
just wanted to establish that there
wasn't some internal sense of
sensitivity but rather we establish that
this kind of information that being
zapped is likely to results in
real-world harm that we already know
about so it's kind of an externalized
and we don't have the either the
expertise or resources to go through
even a sample of like the hundreds of
articles that we're hand coding and do a
informational sensitivity analysis but
we can say something some general things
about some things that we think
increased the sensitivity ability
factors that increase either either the
the vulnerabilities that paths to risks
the threats to which people were exposed
and that is to specific harms or or the
possibility that you will learn from
them learn about them and thus some of
these these harms will will come to
realization just kind of following up on
that because the way you define harm I
could say for example that based on the
result of data less resources flow to my
school district and more flow to someone
other and that lowers that that results
in lower housing prices for everyone in
this district that would seem like a
harm relative to your definition and yet
it's also a societal decision that
that's what we're trying to accomplish
sure sure and in in many in some cases
we are and I didn't go into this like
the harm the harm fairness framework
which is something else but whether a
decision is fair or not depends on how
you distribute it harms sometimes harms
are deserved sometimes there are it's a
good trade-off however if we if there's
a social benefit and we impose
individual harms differentially on
particular people simply because of
their especially people who are
historically disadvantaged there I would
say there's a there's a justice problem
with that if we if we make errors and
the errors in our decision-making affect
some class of people generate harms
through those those errors in
classification harm is not harm by
itself is not unethical in order to say
in order to say what you're protecting
against you have to we believe that you
need to measure it with reference to
some outcome that affects people's lives
and some measure of that and some
counterfactual of what you would have
done otherwise whether it is do a
computation that doesn't reveal their
you know doesn't allow you to infer
about them individually not have
collected their data in the first place
given them a a right to challenge the
the result or then you can say whether
that that choice resulted in some harm
and then you can start to think about
whether that harm is is fair just
reasonable based on the the social
benefit etc
I guess I guess I'm struggling in the
sense that so excited I understand I
think I understand the approach but
particularly this seems good
particularly in the context of big data
it seems like as challenging for two
differences the freedom everybody
privacy content opinion is nearly
impossible to kind of upper bound and
then which that information can then
flow to others we use is typically
through produces corporate channels
where you really have no birthday yeah
how people something like a data broker
model or not
where you have where there's the entire
business model where people are
commingling other people's data and then
selling it for purposes not these are
typically you may think these things
that really don't see until like a news
article goes out so for instance the
ability to sell a phone location
information to target further target
victims of intimate partner violence you
know I mean when we know about them we
can say oh cool that's a harm we should
be worried about that just like one
example of a whole multitude of
different ways in which large-scale
information can be used to target people
so I guess um it seems like right it's a
hard thing to really quantify I think it
I think it is a hard thing to quantify
and so
but that doesn't think that you have to
you can ignore harm sensitivity identify
bullies are thank you qualify in big
data as well that you you can ignore
these when you're making decisions and
if you we think that there are some
characteristics that like retaining the
data for a longer time that we don't
know what it will be used for but we can
anticipate that whatever they can sent
it to whatever they understood as use at
time T there's going to be a whole space
of uses it time T plus 10 so so there
are we can we can anticipate that there
are some risk factors that affect phone
a possible vulnerabilities threats
identify ability and that those
increasing risk factors justify some
additional form of control whether it's
in terms of control it you know data
collection or giving them a a you know
providing a a right to to see where
their data is gone and a right of action
on the of legal action or or some other
or in a you know an insurance fund that
they can you know if they they show
reasonable evidence that they were there
was a increased probability downstream
that this affected them that they can
collect a little bit from the insurance
so there there are all sorts of
mitigating controls you could put in
place and from a social design point of
view looking at what factors are
increasing vulnerability sensitivity
identifiability what do you go you know
what are you going to do about
your comment near the end that you know
the government data has many different
uses was a nice reminder that in this
meeting were mainly talk about
statistical agencies official statistics
which was about police departments
struggling what to do with their with
their data as part of you know data
mandates and taking water dominantly
public records out of out of a rest
records out of you know paper files and
wondering about putting them online and
the uses of that data in that
conversation were talked about this you
know there's two kinds of uses Wiley
there are they they're the
oceanographers in the and a fishermen
statistical analysis but our
photographers and is for like a
journalist to find a story that you know
draws attention you know something
that's going wrong in the system and I
would and I point to different both
different levels of units of analysis
where someone is inherently interested
in the individual versus the population
unit of analysis different different
modes of analysis which are easier like
are they are they using the modes of
statistical computation and data
transformation do they need to do record
linkage do they need to run Bayesian
statistics on it to do cleaning on it
those are different you could think of
those computation versus different
different overall goals for the use
official decision communication we
collect a large survey so we can set the
unemployment rate so we can calculate
that that's what what the the budget
pays budget line pays for and all of
this and so that's the big direct
purpose a lot of people there's a much
broader social benefit that is not
accounted for in the same way we have
traces of that through a research
papers etc and business use and then
there's also a an employed requirement
that things the government dude should
be accountable transparent in some way
and that's those are those are also
that's a separate dimension from whether
it's individual or more population them
that's those are the distinctions that
are trying to make thank you for that
population individual normal distinction
and as a this is an unindicted
co-conspirators